today on the matt well show joe biden
goes to buffalo to exploit the dead for
his own political gain also a
pro-abortion activist at a congressional
hearing claims that men can get pregnant
there are several important clips from
that hearing that we'll watch and
discuss today the media is now panicking
over a new virus monkey pox should we
join them in their hysteria no we should
not we'll talk about it and msnbc warns
that homeschooling is a secret plot to
destroy the public education system
they're wrong about that it's not a
secret in our daily cancellation a
theologian says that it's better for
black babies to be aborted than adopted
by white families this is what passes
for theology these days we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Applause]
[Music]
as rates rise the best thing you could
do is pay off debt before it gets worse
you cannot let larger interest payments
drag you down this is why it's very
important to take action right now call
our friends at american financing and
take advantage of a free mortgage review
it's a 10-minute call where you'll learn
about custom loan options that can save
you a great deal of money look there's
no pressure no obligation there's no
upfront or hidden fees all they ask is
to have a simple conversation around
ways to save up to a thousand dollars a
month plus tens of thousands long term
you don't have to reset your loan to get
those savings and you can choose any
term 10 years and over that way you're
not wasting money on years you don't
need so you're saving money uh it's it's
quick it's easy all of that there's no
reason not to do it think of how much
that can help then make the call to
american financing to learn more now if
you start soon you could close in as
fast as 10 days until you're saving
money uh
fast and this is something we all need
right now so what you got to do is call
866 569-4711
that's
866-569-4711-866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls one eight two
three three four nmls consumeraccess.org
yeah we know and uh will often remark
upon the fact that president joe biden
is a senile arthritic brittle old mr
magoo who can barely speak or walk or
feed himself he has the awareness and
governing ability of a moldy loaf of
bread he's an ancient decrepit
feeble old loser this we know and you
know these are important points that we
should raise and often do but let's not
allow that to distract us from the fact
that biden is also
a morally vacuous huckster and
manipulative con artist without a shred
of integrity or decency he is decaying
in front of the world his dementia has
become a global spectacle only because
he put himself in this position
due to his insane lust for power and
prominence
he's pathetic then but not pitiable
there's nothing to pity he's done this
to himself and to us
to the entire country and the world
so this is all important to establish as
we consider joe biden's trip to buffalo
yesterday biden of course
never saw fit to visit the victims in
waukesha where he crazed black
supremacists mowed down and killed six
white people including a young child as
you recall the white house said that
they didn't have the resources or assets
to
manage a trip of that kind
though yesterday the new press secretary
karen gene pair uh justified this by
reminding us that um biden has been to
many communities you know he has lots of
experience
visiting communities it's just that one
community up in waukesha that he decided
not to visit you know because of the
assets and resources
somehow though the regime was able to
scrounge together all of the assets and
resources needed to not only visit
buffalo but also deliver a televised
prime time speech so within a month they
didn't have the assets and resources to
even stop by waukesha and
maybe have some words of condolence for
the families of the victims maybe the
parents of the child who was mowed down
didn't have the assets and resources for
that but within three days they had all
the assets and resources to go have a
big spectacle uh you know visit the
victims and then but then also give a
speech
climbing atop the dead bodies using them
as his political platform and one of the
most cynical and exploitative displays
we've yet seen from this white house and
that's saying a lot
biden railed against white supremacy
calling it a poison
he bravely denounced it and then warned
that it has been allowed to grow and
fester right before our eyes
then he pulled out his left the left's
new favorite boogeyman replacement
theory quote unquote and paraded it
around for a while let's watch that
what happened here is simple and
straightforward terrorism
terrorism
domestic terrorism
violence inflicted in the service of
hate
and the vicious thirst for power
that defines one group of people
being inherently inferior to any other
group
a hate
that through the media
and politics the internet
has radicalized angry alienated lost and
isolated individuals into falsely
believing
that they will be replaced that's the
word replaced
by the other
by people who don't look like them
and who are therefore
in the perverse ideology that they
possess and being fed lesser beings
i and all of you reject the lie
i call on all americans to reject the
lie and i condemn those
who spread the lie for power
political gain
and for profit
well he certainly knows a thing or two
about spreading lies for power and
political gain so we should as they say
trust
the experts although
can't really trust him here now is it
true that the shooter in buffalo was a
white supremacist as biden claims yes
that's clear enough from his words and
actions is it true that biden or anybody
else in the democrat party actually care
about racism extremism or terrorism no
that is clear enough from their words
and actions or lack thereof as the case
may be
the democrats are of course very
selective in the forms of violence
terrorism and racism they denounce
nothing to be gained politically from
denouncing or even so much as
acknowledging black supremacy anti-white
racism and left-wing terrorism all of
which are significantly more common and
mainstream than white supremacy and
anti-black racism significantly more
even when it comes to white supremacy
biden's interest is not in simply
denouncing it
his greater point is to denounce his
political adversaries by connecting them
to it and to the shooting never mind the
fact that the shooter is an incoherent
lunatic
who apparently wore a hazmat suit to
school for a week
he had threatened to shoot up his school
a year a year before
a few weeks before the grocery store
attack he beat a cat to death beheaded
it and then buried it in his backyard
and he bragged about this online which
is how we know that this happened and he
said
that he felt blank
after slaughtering the animal
now the shooter
may have been racist he was
but that's not the principle factor
that drove him to become a mass murderer
he was and is a psychotic violent empty
nihilistic
lunatic
who like every other kid in america was
locked in his home for months on end and
encouraged to live his entire life
online even more than he already had
been presumably up to that juncture
and it was and that's relevant here even
though nobody is talking about it
because it was at that point that the
shooter as he says in his rambling
manifesto quote-unquote
which by the way i don't like that word
for these uh for these psychos who go on
on shooting sprees calling it a
manifesto to me seems to like legitimize
it
um
but that's actually what the left wants
to do that's what the media want want to
do
but
as we're informed he first out of sheer
boredom
being locked inside started going down
the various internet rabbit holes on
4chan and other sites
he developed through this process a
totally unintelligible world view that
no honest person could describe as right
wing or left wing or any other wing
he's a demented vacant human being
killing
primarily for whatever sick thrill he
derives from it that's why he beheaded a
cat only a week a few weeks before
and you took
this kid then you put him in his house
isolate uh spending all the time online
but that's
that's a connection that's an issue that
we're not we're just we're we're not
gonna talk about that at all
now democrats want to turn this raving
lunatic into some sort of politically
engaged conservative who watched fox
news
even though he specifically said that he
hates fox news
but that's what makes him useful to them
and so that's what they're doing
this is obviously an attempt to silence
their high profile opposition but it's
also like tucker carlson but it's also a
message to everybody else they're
railing against replacement theory
because replacement theory is yet
another thing that can be turned into a
phantom for them it's another umbrella
which they can spread out over top the
heads of millions of americans
and that's what they want to do that's
what they are doing with it
just like white supremacy
it's like unfortunately
it's not even coherent anymore to talk
about white supremacy because although
there are actual white supremacists that
exist
like the one up in buffalo
you know sadly the left has taken that
term and they've applied it to just
millions of people all at once i mean
they've made everything into white
supremacy
so then when an actual white supremacist
comes along
and thank god there aren't very many of
them but when an actual one comes along
and they say the word white supremacist
it doesn't mean anything anymore
and this is what they do with these
labels
doing the same thing now with the
replacement theory now any criticism of
the left's racial agenda especially any
critique of anti-white racism becomes
replacement theory
so biden is saying to the public
we in the democrat party can talk openly
about demographic shifts we can declare
the democrat demographics is destiny we
played all that the whole montage for
yesterday of people in the media
liberals saying that
we can literally cheer out loud at news
that the white population is declining
we can work to explicitly marginalize
and exclude certain races from
institutions namely white people also
asians and certain institutions and we
can do all of this but you cannot notice
it or point it out
because if you do they're saying to us
then you're lumped in with a mass
killing psycho who wore hazmat suits and
butchered cats for fun before shooting
up a grocery store
threats and emotional blackmails all
these people have
they can't directly silence you to the
extent that they want but they can
manipulate coerce and shame you
whatever it takes to stop you from
stating the
obvious you know yesterday it was
announced that the so-called
disinformation board is being put on
pause quote unquote and the newly
appointed minister of truth scary
poppins will be stepping down the white
house hilariously blamed disinformation
for shutting down the disinformation
board which as i said on tucker's show
last night it's like it's like a a fire
department closing down shop because
there was a fire you know it's like that
yeah the new fire department opens up in
your town and then you have a fire in
your house and you call them and they
say oh i don't want to deal with the
fire then they just they shut down they
close they close the entire thing
if the disinformation board is supposed
to fight disinformation
then why didn't they fight it i mean the
first thing it ought to be able to do is
fight the disinformation about the
disinformation board
of course as we know what we were saying
about the disinformation board was not
disinformation
when they say disinformation what they
really mean is
inconvenient information
just as michael scott defined hate
speech as speech i hate which is also
how liberals define it incidentally
false information is now defined by the
left as in information i wish was false
or feel is false
or here's information that it would be
better for us if it was false and
therefore it is
and yet the lesson here is that all we
had to do when it came to the
disinformation board
to take down biden's ministry of truth
all we had to do is
notice it
and point at it and say look what
they're doing over there
it took just a little bit of sunlight
and the thing shriveled and died away
that's how you know by the way when you
when you when someone is doing something
and then you notice them doing it and
they stop
that tells you something about what they
were doing i know this as a parent like
i walk into a room
and the kids look like they're they're
up to something up to no good but as
soon as i walk in they just stop
whatever they were doing
what were you guys doing in here but
nothing
well you know 100 certain it's nothing
good whatever it was
now we still have that power as
americans
to some extent anyway
which is why the tyrants rely so heavily
on fear tactics and emotional coercion
and shame
but they have no shame themselves which
is why they'll even use a mass shooting
to their advantage whatever it takes to
scare you into silence
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well a new virus just dropped grabbing
all the headlines i'm sure making covert
pretty jealous this is from fox it says
massachusetts health officials confirmed
on wednesday that the first case of
monkey pox a rare but potentially
serious virus in the united states so
far this year has been confirmed monkey
pox causes similar symptoms to smallpox
including fever headache muscle aches
exhaustion chills and skin lesions at
least seven cases of the virus have been
reported this month in the uk health
authorities have said
uh the individual contracted monkey pox
in massachusetts had recently traveled
to canada
and officials said they're conducting
contact tracing
um
now
this is another so there are some
similarities that we that we can already
see here which is uh remember we heard
about
we first heard about uh
about covid and then there was that
that virus lab right there in in wuhan
and we're like is there a connection and
we were too told for years ah no there's
no connection until finally they said
you know it might be connected
um
so similar thing here it's like there
was that it wasn't that case of some
monkeys that escaped in pennsylvania a
few months ago and then someone got in
contact with them and became sick
that's up there in the northeast and
then in massachusetts you got the monkey
box
is there a connection
well if there is they're not going to
tell us and it'll be they at least won't
tell us for a couple years it's going to
be conspiracy theory until one day it's
not
uh now we're also told with monkey pox
that uh it has a 10 fatality rate
and that's all over the headlines too
you know
10 fatality rate well one thing we
should keep in mind is that the monkey
pox is uh
when we hear about the fatality rate
what they're really telling us is
this is the fatality rate in africa
and the fatality rate for everything is
higher in africa so keep that in mind
and here's the other thing to keep in
mind
when we if we start seeing more
headlines about this about the monkey
bugs
there are always going to be
exotic scary diseases circulating
through the global population and the
national population
that is always going to be the case
like you could scare yourself anytime
you want
and it does seem like some americans
have this insatiable desire to be
terrified all the time and so if that's
how you get your kicks then good news is
you can go on google anytime and look up
exotic diseases and you'll find that
there's a lot of them
all over the place including in america
so that's always going to be the case
right now there's
what they're telling us is one case of
monkey pox
in the entire united states a population
of 330 million
or more
and um
that gets national headlines
like it's totally unsustainable you
can't make we're gonna make national
headlines over every
i guess so like every scary disease that
even one person gets in this country
it's now gonna be national headline
you just have to decide the decision you
have to make uh and this was a decision
that we all confronted with kovid and
hopefully you made up your mind then but
if you haven't then you got to make it
make it up now
just decide are you going to allow
yourself allow your life to be taken
over and dominated
by fear or not
a lot of scary things out there in the
world
a lot of things that could kill you
and the the really the scariest thing of
all is that there are a lot of things
that could kill you
and one one day one of those things
will kill you
like 100
so your fatality rate is will be your
personal fatality rate for life for
living life is 100
but are you going to allow yourself to
be dominated by fear over that or are
you just going to live your life that's
the decision you have to make
and here's another thing you can ask
yourself just kind of uh and i'm not
saying that this that this is uh that
this works 100 of the time
but
whenever the national media is is uh
trying to stir up panic over something
and they're telling us about something
making a big deal out of something um
one thing you can ask yourself is
if this was a hundred years ago
would i have heard about this event at
all
or would have potentially gone my entire
life and never heard about it
like if it was a hundred years ago and
you live as i live in tennessee and one
person in pennsylvania had a scary
disease i would just never ever be aware
of that i'd never know and i'd live my
life and i'd be fine not knowing that
if somebody in your local community has
a scary communicable disease then you
even 100 years ago you would have found
out about that
so again i mean there are things that uh
could be happening way out there in the
world that don't immediately affect you
right now that you should know about
but the problem with with living in the
internet age is that we're just being
bombarded by all of that information
constantly like 99 of it you don't
really need to know
all right um the media is moving on here
the media is doing the usual number on
republicans who voted against the quote
access to baby formula act
that's the name of the act anyway
and uh they named the act that which
means that you can't vote against it
because they that's what they call the
act so if you vote against the bill then
you're voting against access to baby
formula who could be opposed to
accessing baby formula
well nine republicans did vote against
it
and of course people on social media
including
some conservatives who just like always
fall for this
or there's some bill with a certain name
that sounds like everybody should agree
with it and then a few republicans vote
against it and then even conservatives
well why would they vote against this
this is they must be these are super
villains they they don't want people to
get baby formula
well
here's what the act actually does uh it
says the newsweek articles nine
republicans and house representatives
have voted against a bill that aims to
facilitate the purchase of baby formula
for those on low-income federal support
programs the access to baby form the act
also known as h.r 7791
would allow low-income women to buy more
baby formula through the federal women
infant and children program uh it
received uh bipartisan support everyone
voted for it except for nine the nine
lawmakers who voted against the bill
were uh andy biggs lauren bobert matt
gates um
louis gourmet uh gomer there we go uh
paul goes our marjorie taylor green clay
higgins thomas massey and chip roy
another rule we're doing rules of thumb
today another rule of thumb is is uh and
again nothing could be 100 percent no
politician especially is right 100 of
the time but if thomas massey votes
against a bill
you should definitely take a second look
at it because he's rarely wrong on these
kinds of things
uh and as it turns out i don't think he
was here either i don't think he was
wrong on this
so this is a bill to expand baby formula
access
for people on government entitlements
well
how about solving the problem for
everyone
i think that's kind of the issue with
the bill why are we singling out a
certain
sliver of the population who are on
government entitlements and expanding
access for them how about everyone solve
the problem for everyone
don't single people out and and assign
special privileges when it comes to baby
formula
no the issue is that there's not about
enough baby formula for everybody and
they're actually babies in the hospital
right now
because of malnutrition i mean we have
in the united states of america the year
2022
i'm not usually one to pull out though
it's the year 2022 thing but this is one
time where i think it applies
in the year 2022 in in modern western
society we should not have babies going
to the hospital because they don't have
enough food available
and we do
in biden's america
and this is a problem that affects
everybody it should be solved for
everybody
okay
and and it can be solved because this is
a problem largely created by the fda
as we've talked about on this show they
have there are many different brands of
baby formula available all over the uk
that are perfectly safe even arguably
healthier and better for babies
than a lot of baby formula used here
and the fda has stopped
that baby fuller from being imported to
the united states
so look at them how about get them out
of the way
and solve the problem for everybody
well there was a con congressional
committee hearing on abortion yesterday
um i'm going to play a few of these
clips and we'll start with this this is
a pro-abortion activist named amy um
we'll call her being questioned on the
exact difference between a born child
and an unborn child
and uh
kind of going through the process here
you know starting with uh an adult
and then going all the way down
to the moment of birth
you know and uh and then you stop the
tape right there at the moment of birth
there's a baby there's a human being now
rewind the clock another five seconds
what changes isn't that still
whatever that being was at the moment of
birth
was it not that five seconds earlier
that's the that's the line of
questioning here and let's see how it
goes
so so abortion should be allowed then by
your definition for any reason for any
purpose at any stage right
i trust people to make decisions about
their body and then when relevant i
think that they need to consult their
medical
practitioners okay and not if it is
listen let me just ask you this question
if it is not lawful and morally
acceptable to take the life of a
ten-year-old child i assume you agree
with that right that would be wrong
correct
i believe that okay and a two-year-old
child same thing that would be murder we
would all agree that's wrong then what
is the principal distinction between the
human being that is two years old or
nine months old or one week old or an
hour old than one that is eight inches
further up the birth canal in the uterus
what's the difference why is it okay in
the latter case and not the former cases
i trust people to determine what to do
with their own body
full stop
oh that's it sorry she said full stop at
the end so that's that
she wins so all you got you could say
something completely stupid and uh that
doesn't make it but as long as you say
full stop at the end
full stop
see i just did it so it doesn't matter
like whatever you said just say full
stop and you win the argument little
known fact
uh but you can't she can't answer the
question as always with the uh
pro-abortion people they can't answer
the most basic questions about their
position and it's a very good question
as was posed there what is the principal
distinction between the child
immediately after birth and immediately
before
did you notice how she she she
was even hesitant to affirm that it
would be wrong to kill a ten-year-old
child
there was that there was like a very
noticeable very loud moment of a pause a
moment of silence there hesitation
when she was asked well clearly killing
a ten-year-old child we all agree
there's this pause
i believe that yeah i believe that's
wrong
oh good well okay glad we're on the same
page with that at least
though probably not for very long
because
there is no principal distinction that
is actually the answer and so whatever
argument you make
for killing the baby five seconds before
the baby is born
that argument would apply to a child at
any stage
alone
especially in the earliest months right
after birth because the child
you know you could try to
hinge your whole argument on
the fact that the child in the womb is
entirely dependent on their mother for
survival
which is true but that doesn't do that
doesn't change the fact that it's still
a human being
and if your moral worth and your legal
rights
on you not being dependent upon others
for survival well then i got bad news
for people on welfare
right
i've got bad news for a lot of people in
this country who are dependent on others
for survival but especially newborn
babies who in many ways are
you know more not many ways in fact in
almost every way are more demanding of
their mother's time and attention and
and
body and very life than the child was in
the womb
now this same
activist was also asked whether men can
become pregnant
and she's not a biologist as far as i
know but she still actually had an
answer to this question let's listen
what do you say a woman is
i believe that everyone can identify for
themselves
okay
do you believe then that men can become
pregnant and have abortions
yes
i mean she has no choice but to say that
of course but she has no definition of
woman men can become pregnant
these are these are statements now being
made in congressional hearings on the
record
i also i loved here's a moment that i
that i really like this is kind of
reversing the roles here
now it's a pro-life person testifying
and a pro-abortion
uh politician questioning her
and the pro-life person will get her
name in a second i don't remember her
name but she she does something here
that i that i'm very glad she does she
makes up she makes a point
she kind of has a rebuttal that's very
simple but i'm i'm happy that she did it
because i had exactly the effect
that it was destined to have let's watch
this
is candidly
and openly calling for a nationwide
ban
on all abortions with no exceptions
for rape
or incest
and if i've got that wrong i would
invite miss foster to correct me
do i have a wrong yes or no
um if we added rape and incest
exceptions would you vote for it
okay
i reclaim my time of course
there we go perfect that was catherine
glenn foster was the woman being
questioned there by representative jamie
raskin
and uh i'm so glad she responded that
way
because that's exactly what you should
do
it's when when the
when the pro-abortion people go on and
on about there's no exceptions for rape
and incest yeah but would it matter to
you if there was
okay let's say that we made the
exception would you would you vote for
would make any difference to you at all
well i i i reclaim my time
no responsibility because because of
course the answer is it doesn't make a
difference to them
they they wouldn't make any exception
they don't believe in exceptions anyway
it's like so it doesn't matter it's an
irrelevant point
so that's why you already this is so
often the case with the left when
they're when you're engaging with the
left
um
there are so many moves that they make
where if you engage then you've already
lost so once they start going on about
should there be exceptions for rape and
incest
when you engage with that
you lose
because that's all they want to talk
about
um
then that's why the correct answer is
but what does that do with anything
would would it make a difference to you
no it wouldn't okay well let's move on
then why are we even talking about it
they do the same damn thing they do they
just say the same thing kind of thing on
every topic but they do the same things
of course on gender with transgenderism
well there are
there are people who are who are
intersex and it could appear to be a man
but really this is a woman because of
the sexual you know deformities and
okay well
are you saying that a person who identif
a man who identifies as a woman but is
not intersex doesn't count as a woman
well no i'm not saying that okay well
why are you talking about intersex what
does this do with anything
um
going back to the pregnant man issue i
just wanted to play this for you a uh
this kind of went viral yesterday a
woman who works in a birthing center was
on tick-tock and she would like you to
know that in fact she has dealt with
plenty of pregnant men thank you very
much let's listen to her
i haven't been living under a rock
you've probably heard that we're
supposed to start using terms like
birthing
as somebody who works in a birthing
center and works alongside midwives um i
had my children with midwives my mother
is a midwife um you're absolutely right
you're supposed to take care of pregnant
people
um but not all people who can give birth
are women
you can call yourself whatever you want
if you have a patient who says i am a
woman giving birth hear me roar you can
tell her that during labor but if you're
going to take care of people who can
give birth you better get rid of this
rhetoric pretty quick
because i hope you never get hired to
take care of people
if this is the way you think because to
me
if i was
um a person who could give birth but
didn't identify as a woman i would not
want to see you and i would not trust
you
you know that's not much of a threat i
mean if i was an ob gyn or
you know if i if i if i worked in a
birthing center
and uh there's a man who claimed to be
pregnant and didn't want to hire me he
didn't want to be me to be involved
i'm fine with that you know i'd be fine
with that because that man whatever he's
pregnant with it ain't a baby i know
that okay
that's a guy who went a little too heavy
over chipotle or maybe he's it's some
sort of alien parasitic infestation i
don't know what it is but if he's a man
he's not pregnant so i'm perfect i don't
want to be in the room for that
whatever's about that whatever's about
to come out and wherever it's coming out
i don't want to be there for it
she also says that uh what patients will
say i'm a woman giving birth really is
that do they do they say that
do women like walk into birthing centers
or to the maternity wards i'm i'm a
woman about to give birth no i don't
think they like ever say that because
everyone already understands that you're
going to give birth we already know
you're a woman you need to clarify that
but this is very good you know i think
we want the left
that moment in the congressional hearing
this like yes please go all in
on men can give birth be as explicit
as you could possibly be in in it like
just tell us all about it all the time i
think very good please yeah go with that
please
democrats go with that
finally stand up for the pregnant men
you know this is the only the only time
that people on the left
will ever speak up for men like the only
time you'll ever hear them say well what
about men
is when it comes to pregnancy
the only time they're worried about men
being marginalized they'll never bring
it up in any other topic in any other
situation the only time is when it comes
to pregnancy
the only types of men that they'll stick
up for are the pregnant ones
which don't exist so i guess that tells
you what you need to know
all right what else do we got here um
let me tell you okay so this is from
msnbc there's kind of been circulating
for a few days i just want to mention
this
their headline is how the conservative
christian right is hijacking
homeschooling
says public education has become public
enemy number one
the actor kirk cameron opines in a
promotion for the homeschool awakening
his documentary scheduled to hit
theaters in june the documentary funded
by the trinity broadcasting network and
cameron's own cam fam studios argues
that parents should be homeschooling
their children in the wake of the
pandemic however as cameron's quote
indicates this latest project of
conservative evangelical education is
another salvo in the ongoing evangelical
war against public schools
it continues it should come as no
surprise that evangelicals
fundamentalists and other religious
conservatives have fought against public
education since the u.s supreme court's
194 decision in brown versus board of
education the prospect of integrated
schools led the creation of many
segregation academies private schools
um designed to keep african-american
children undesirable immigrant groups
away from white children but there was
another more insidious way to circumvent
integration homeschooling and then we
get to it so homeschooling was invented
for racist reasons and then we hear more
about how homeschooling is a
conservative christian racist conspiracy
to destroy the public
school system and finally it ends with
this
homeschooling may have greater appeal
now because of these debates and the
desire for parents to play a big part in
their children's educational life
may also arise out of pandemic concerns
but parents unfamiliar with the existing
networks of homeschooling run the danger
of being drawn into christian
conservative networks and theocratic
teaching
cameron says cameron's says that
that people choosing homeschooling are
having an awakening
but the public needs to awaken to the
reality that public schools may
disappear if people with his extreme
beliefs have their way
i always love this as a homeschooler
myself and having been
spent spent plenty of time
around homeschoolers
i've been to a lot of homeschooling
conventions and so forth i've spoken at
homeschooling conventions
any time any like this attempt to paint
homeschoolers as dangerous extreme
you know you have to be careful you're
gonna get drawn into this dangerous
world
of homeschooling like it's a like fight
club or something and then you go and
you meet homeschoolers and they're just
the nicest
most polite people you'll ever meet
that's it
that's the only i'll tell you that's for
me
as a cynical bastard the only slightly
weird thing about being around a lot of
homeschoolers is just that they're so
nice
and i'm not used to that being around a
lot of nice people and so that's the
only thing that takes some adjustment
but outside of that just normal nice
people
and yet
um
some of what's being claimed here is
true in a way nothing not not any of the
dumb stuff about racism no that's true
but
um homeschooling is a threat to the
public school
system yeah it certainly is
okay because the public school system
largely still exists
people feel they have no other option
public school system doesn't exist now
because it's doing such a great job
and people are excited about it and
they're excited to send their kids
like some parents are excited to send
their kids to public school most are not
and the only reason it's it exists and
it continues to thrive in the way that
it is
is because uh people feel they have no
other option
i mean the public schools are doing a
terrible job generally speaking of
educating kids
kids coming out of school today
are you know you've got kids coming out
of school they can barely read they know
nothing about history they know nothing
about grammar they know you know they
they know a lot about all the different
new pronouns but they don't know much
else besides that
and this continues because people feel
they have no other option and so
homeschool is a threat
to the public school system
because it tells parents you do have
another option and not only that but the
other option is not it doesn't have to
be private school
okay it's not doesn't mean you got to
spend 40 grand a year or something
sending your kid to a super expensive
private school now you have another
option that's actually free
and that is a threat to the public
school monopoly so yeah you're damn
right about that okay one other thing um
this report here says three paintings by
titans of modern art have sold for a
total of almost 166 million dollars at
auction confirming the buoyancy of the
global market
in a sale of modern arts in new york on
tuesday a total of more than 408 million
was paid for for works by artists
including picasso monet
and then some other artists i can't
pronounce uh ten works sold for more
than ten million dollars each at an
auction broadcast live on instagram
and um
says attracting nearly twenty thousand
viewers pablo picasso's
fem new couche a sensuous depiction of
the artist's muse and lover marie
therese walter went for 67 million one
of the highest prices ever achieved for
a portrait of walter whose relationship
with picasso began when she was 17. okay
so this wait a second
so that's it that's the that's the
painting right there that's the portrait
of his what
that so he
he was having sex with an octopus
is that that's the portrait of his lover
so his lover was uh
a spongebob character i've seen more
beautiful art by the way in a spongebob
like in a spongebob meme on twitter than
that right there
and somebody spent 67 million dollars
to immortalize
pablo picasso's octopus girlfriend
i'm sorry i don't care look it it you
could say all you want to art is
subjective
no yeah but that's garbage is what that
is
okay it's the rule that you've heard
from me before just like with dancing
same goes and and poetry same goes for
art if i can do it and i could do
exactly that
then it is not art
but you know it's sort of irrelevant
because we know that the modern art
market is really just a big giant money
laundering operation anyway so yeah if
you're going to
launder your money then i guess why not
do it with a 67 million dollar
painting of a cartoon octopus
let's get now to the comment section
carter says we do care about aliens all
of us conspiracy theories theorists just
aren't on social media anymore
well then you need to get back on social
media uh carter because i had so i have
someone to talk to because you're
leaving me alone
all right out there and i want to talk
about aliens and there's no one to talk
about with so can you come back so that
we can have these conversations
um
tie my shoes says i'm starting the walsh
replacement theory matt's insane ultra
spg pull will conquer and replace the
other hosts at daily wire well that is
one replacement theory that we don't i
don't we don't talk about
um
just let just let it work in the
background
matt helm says matt what's more annoying
for you people who leave their shopping
carts in the parking lot or men who
choose the urinal right next to you in a
public restroom when there are plenty of
other options i can't decide
uh
that's a tough call you know because
these are all
sociopaths but i would go with the
urinal because that to me is just so
egregious and i really have to start
questioning your motives i cannot
understand it but it's it's incredibly
common
this is an epidemic i don't understand
it
and it's by the way it's not just i mean
it's bad enough if you're already you're
already at a urinal and there's other
urinals and there's plenty of space but
then the guy comes right next to you
right that's bad enough but then there's
also
where you create this problem
because maybe there are three urinals in
a row
and then and you come in and there's no
one at any urinal and then you go right
in the middle
guaranteeing that the next person who
come in comes in is gonna have to be
next to you like what's your game here
why are you doing that you
you have a corner spot you have the the
sought after corner spot all to yourself
and you go for the middle
yeah thanks for bringing that up uh
rob coy says
this was my real reaction when seeing
the video of ufos not impressed
oh oh so you're not impressed okay rob
well sorry that you're not impressed
sorry you're not impressed by
um spacecraft that have traveled across
galaxies to come here i'm sorry it's
just a it's just a craft from 90
billion light years away
an entire
civilization that we know nothing about
traveling through our skies i'm sorry it
doesn't impress you
let's let the aliens know come you know
rob's not impressed
he's not alone i mean none of it no
one's impressed apparently
think of how that makes the aliens feel
too that's something we didn't talk
about yesterday
is think about how insulting this is for
them
that they're coming all this way
and they're probably imagining i mean
they've been in the spaceship for like
for generations probably the amount of
time it would take to traverse these
distances even if they're traveling at
the speed of light somehow and they come
all this way they're probably imagining
that when they get here they're just
like imagining how shocked everyone's
going to be to finally see them and then
they get here and everyone just goes
just keeps walking
oh it's aliens hey what's up
look at how insulting that is for them
and how discouraging
anticlimactic
casey says matt you're an idiot she-hulk
is canonical she's literally in the
comics an actual superhero you have no
idea what you're talking about
well i admit i have no idea what i'm
talking about with she-hulk because i'm
a grown 35 year old man
and so that's why i admit yeah i don't
my
my she-hulk knowledge knowledge leaves a
lot to be desired i suppose
um
what do you mean she's canonical what is
this holy scripture like she's canonical
what does that even mean
she's an actual superhero no she's not
she's she's made up
what do you mean an actual superhero
she's not real i don't know if you know
that
and i don't care if she's in the comics
or not that doesn't mean that we need to
have a film about her it's not an
interesting concept okay like we've seen
it we get it
how many times let me casey i ask you
this
when is it enough
how many times do you need to see
the same story
over and over again
because it's literally just the same
story
every superhero movie people debate
what's the best superhero movie they're
all the same it's just the same story
every time someone who's stronger than
the average person he has superpowers
like it's the same story arc the same
story over and over we just travel that
arc back and forth back forever
you've seen it 70 times in 70 different
films how many more do you need
before we can say to hollywood together
as one collective voice we get it guys
we've seen it
good stuff
let's move on there are other kinds of
stories you could be telling
i think
america would be a much smarter place if
we spent more time reading less time
watching she-hulk and today's the day to
start because at 7 pm eastern is a live
signing of jonathan isaac's new book why
i stand published by dw books isaac was
the lone nba player not to kneel for the
national anthem during a league wide
demonstration in support of black lives
matter his story is courageous it's also
inspiring the live signing happens on
the premiere collectibles youtube
channel to get your signed copy and a
chance to ask jonathan a question go to
premierecollectables.com
isaac and after that at 8 pm it's bench
ben shapiro's third thursday book club
ben's going to take you through herman
melville's classic moby dick you can go
over his notes and analysis and take
your questions as well check it out
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that helped form the key pillars of
western civilization and help define
america and we're going to do it live
with thousands of you our daily wire
members
i'm going to be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm gonna
draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm gonna be
answering your questions along the way
so we actually do read the book together
you join the book club you are going to
get smarter you're going to get more
knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's going to change the way you think
this is not like any other book club
you've ever been a part of to join third
thursday book club head over to
dailywire.com subscribe where new
members get 20 off with coach shapiro
and be sure to join ben tonight at 8 p.m
eastern for his third thursday book club
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well our daily cancellation today begins
with a woman named joe lumen who
identifies herself as a pastor and a
theologian
that'll prove to me as we'll see an
absurd
self-identification even by today's
standards it's still pretty absurd in
her twitter bio joe describes herself
her mission this way she says
decolonizing faith and spirituality
dismantling oppression and toxic
theology
she goes by she they pronouns by the way
in case you were interested and she is
also on the board of directors as a
parent board trustee of a charter school
in san diego called the elevate school
and that last detail her status as a
parent board trustee is especially
disturbing and you'll soon see why if
you don't already see it in any case it
would appear that um yesterday joe was
playing in some kind of game show where
contestants are challenged to compose
and then post the most inflammatory
stupid morally vacuous tweet they
possibly can we can assume that she took
home the million dollar prize with this
effort she tweeted
i would rather get an abortion than have
a brown child who ends up being adopted
by white evangelicals it's not a
kindness to children of the global
majority to give them to people who will
traumatize them with self and ancestral
hatred
an abortion is an act of love
yes joe thinks it's better for a black
child to be killed
than adopted by white parents
bad news for colin kaepernick and for
many millions of other people who
according to joe would be better off
dead
and notice how quickly the narrative
shifted from pro-lifers are hypocrites
who oppose abortion but refuse to adopt
children to now
pro-lifers are colonizers who adopt
children quick let's kill all the babies
before they get a chance
there's more to say here but first let's
review the entire exchange that followed
um i responded to joe's tweet in my
usual subtle gentle fashion writing
so you're a racist along with being a
homicidal soulless baby killing ghoul
got it thanks
joe immediately sent the opportunity to
make herself the victim and she wrote
back no not this
quote tweeting me i'm literally freaking
out about about the hatred i'm about to
get for sharing my own choice
and i won't be silenced i won't delete
my post i stand by what i said
a few minutes later she posted again
emphasizing the point i'm genuinely
panicking last time a conservative like
ali beth stuckey and matt walsh quote
tweeted me i got death threats with my
address and the names of my children and
i won't be silenced but i'm begging them
to please tell their followers to be
decent
be decent she cries
cries the woman specifically who just
said she'd rather suck her child's
brains out of his skull
that allow him to live with a white
family
be decent damn you
can you see that decency is her highest
priority
well her first priority is keeping her
children away from races she despises
even if that requires her to kill and
dismember them but after that she really
cares about the whole decency thing
now joe's fellow blue check feminist
came to her aid including a woman named
jen morrison who's a freelance writer
for the new york times and other outlets
as well she commented
you might consider locking your account
just for a little bit i watched walsh
encourage his followers to continue
attacking a suicidal woman they aren't
relentless i'm so sorry
now it's true that the sweet baby gang
is relentless but nothing else she said
approaches the vicinity of the truth i
of course have never told anybody to
attack a suicidal woman in fact i've
never encouraged anyone to attack anyone
so i asked jen to produce evidence
screenshot clip something to back up her
defamatory claim about me but jen
informed me that she doesn't want to
mention the name of my alleged victim or
produce evidence that this event
occurred because that would be really
painful for the woman so we just have to
take her word for it
as somebody in the comments pointed out
this is like the feminist twitter
version of yeah i totally have a
girlfriend but she goes to a different
school
except with an added dose of defamation
towards me in this case
okay now
a few points
first
this is the leftist mo right most
especially the feminist leftist mo a
tale as old as time
empowered feminist woman says something
utterly vile and insane people on the
internet point out that it's vile and
insane
empowered feminist woman immediately
becomes a fainting damsel in distress
crying that she's being attacked and her
feelings are hurt
we might dub this the taylor lorenz
maneuver and a vital part of this
maneuver of course is to claim that
you're getting death threats but to
never produce a single screenshot of any
of those threats
it's very nice of these ladies too i
guess i mean they're getting thousands
of death threats but they respect the
privacy of the people threatening them
with death so they don't post the
screenshots like ever they just never do
they never produce any evidence of any
of these they're getting death threats
every day we never see any of them i
mean you would think if people are
sending you death threats um you'd have
a lot of incentive to post it and like
put their name out there and everything
and i
i don't know i guess they're just being
very considerate
second it's true that my initial
response to joe was um
quite aggressive let's just say and uh
and insulting as well i mean i did call
her a ghoul after all and in a follow-up
tweet i also called her a goblin
and really any monstrous creature from
fantasy novels could work here ghoul
goblin troll vampire werewolf i mean
whatever you want to do
um
the comparison works in any of those
cases but but but should i especially as
a christian
be speaking to and about people this way
that's the question and the answer is
yes
absolutely i should and so should you
it's essential that we do not allow
ourselves to become numb to evil
we have to see it for what it is and
respond to it accordingly this woman
said out loud
that she would rather kill her children
than let a loving white family adopt
them
that's not simply an opposing viewpoint
it's not just an opinion it's not just
like some idea it is pure unadulterated
evil
it's just about the worst thing a human
being could possibly say or think
and my fear is that living in this
twisted culture where where you know
evil straight from the bowels of hell
has been normalized and mainstream we
may not have the kind of gut level
emotional reaction to it that we ought
to have
and that's why we should respond harshly
and severely
here's another good rule of thumb got a
lot of them
when you hear someone on the left say
something disgusting and psychotic
imagine how people 70 years ago would
have responded to that statement and
respond like they would have responded
third and final point
joe says she wants to decolonize faith
well this is ironic because of course
she's doing exactly the opposite
to colonize something is to establish
political control over it
so leftists are engaged in a kind of
ideological colonization attempting to
establish ideological control
over countries institutions cultures and
religions especially christianity
you know they hang the pride flag on
embassies and countries that have no
interest in lgbt pride they force gender
neutrality into foreign languages that
are inherently gendered
they insist that everything conform to
their ideology and they pervert and
corrupt christianity in attempt to turn
it into not just a different faith but
into its own opposite
joe and her comrades envision a
christianity where the self not christ
sits at the center the highest love is
self-love
in their version of christianity
anything done for the sake of the self
is good abortion is an act of love she
says and she means that it's an act of
love for the self
because it is service to the self
she flips christianity on its head
makes it into satanism
and then accuses everybody else of
colonizing the faith
but that's exactly what she is doing of
course and that is why she is today
finally canceled and we'll leave it
there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire